ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าคะวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 11
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะมีฮอ
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันอาทิตย์
วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 10
เดือน
5 เมษายน
มีผช
2565 ปีค.ศต.ค
2022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 12 เดือนเมษายน
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่
โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
10:00 น 10 โมงกี่นาทีคะ 23 นาทีค่ะ
10:23 นาทีเนาะวันนี้นะคะครูฟ้าเนี่ยอ่ะ
เอ๊ะทำไมคะ
คุณ
นัทนักเรียนเนี่ยเคยได้ยินสมัยเมื่อก่อน
วีดีโอวีดีโอเมื่อก่อนครูฟ้าเนี่ยพูดครู
ฟ้าชอบ
วาดรูปนี้
วาดทำไมทุกครั้งเราต้องว่าแค่ภูเขานะว่า
เขาบ้างอ่ะดวงอาทิตย์ก้อนเมฆนี้คือการวาด
รูปสมัยครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบวาดรูปมากๆนะคะวัน
นี้มีเสียงแหลมเลยนะคะวันนี้นะครูฟ้า
เนี่ยก็จะมาบอกมาสอนนักเรียนสมัยว่า
เฮี้ยนรูปต้องทำยังไงไอหาวาดรูปเนี่ยนัก
เรียนจะได้นักเรียนคนไหนเนี่ยชอบว่านตั้ง
นาฬิกาจะได้
วาดรูปยังไงใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะเนาะวันนี้เนี่ย
ครูฟ้าก็จะมาสอนแล้วก็ตอนนี้เนาะครูหญิง
กับครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่บอกนักเรียนว่าครูฟ้าจะ
สอนนักเรียนวาดรูปอะไรไม่บอกนะคะให้นัก
เรียนเนี่ยดูจนหมดวีดีโอได้ค่ะครูหญิงน่า
จะต้อง Share  screen ก่อนนะคะได้ค่ะครู
ฟ้าว่า Share  screen ได้แล้วเนาะนายค่ะ
มีค่ะอ้าวพี่กูฟ้า 2 คนนะคะนักเรียนลูก
ค้าแล้วก็คือฟ้านะคะสองคนอันนี้ก็จะเป็น
กระดาษใช้ค่ะกระดาษสีขาวเขาคือ
เลือกสีหลอดนะอันนี้คือสี
กูว่ามันน่าจะไม่เห็นกูฟ้าสักเขยิบมาทาง
พาของมมีได้ไหมคะมุม
องค์ซ้ายให้เหยียบทางมุมซ้าย
ปลาค่ะ
อย่างนี้แล้วคะ
ค่ะในค่ะ
อ้าครูบาให้นักเรียนเห็นแล้วอะไรคะที่
อยู่บนหน้าจอตอนนี้อันนี้เป็นกระดาษใช่
ไหมสีขาวนะอันนี้คือสีตรงนี้โหตอนนี้สี
อะไรที่นักเรียนเห็นโทรฟ้าสีแดง
ค่ะสีขาว
สีดำค่ะหนาเราจะเลือกใช้สีดำเนอะสีดำวัน
นี้ครูฟ้าจะใช้สีดำเพราะว่าเราวาดรูปสมัย
ไหนลูกวาดรูปก็ใช้สีดำนะคะค่ะโอเคเสร็จ
แล้วก็เขาก็จะเลือก brush โอ้โห
ก็คือเป็นผู้กันใช่ไหมคะประส่ทก็คือ
พู่กันใช้หากผู้กันตรงนี้นะพรุ่งนี้นะคะ
ผู้กัน
แล้วใช้พู่กันแบบไหน
ถึงแม่นักเรียนเห็นแล้วค่ะอ้อนี่คือฟ้าลง
ผู้กัน
มาย้ายศรีวังนั้นอ่ะ
[เพลง]
ตอนนี้ครูฟ้ากำลังหาอะไรขอกำลังลองพู่กัน
วาดปีเหลี่ยมอ๋อคุณฟ้าเริ่มแล้วเหรอคะใช่
ค่ะอ๋อมั้ยฮะใต้ Step ที่ 1 ครูฟ้าว่าสี่
เหลี่ยม
สี่เหลี่ยมอะไรคะผู้หญิงสี่เหลี่ยมที่ครู
ฟ้าว่าใช่ไหมคะใช่ตั้งค่าจีเหลี่ยมผืนผ้า
viewed นักเรียนจำได้ไหมนอนเราเคยสอบครู
ฟ้าว่าสี่เหลี่ยมผืนผ้าแล้วต่อไปว่าอะไร
คะครูฟ้า
ต่อไปนะคะฝันลบนิดหน่อยนะสี่เหลี่ยมมัน
ใหญ่ไปนิดนึงลบสี่เหลี่ยมให้เล็กลง
ใช้ห่าต่อไปนะคะคือพระจะวาดอะไร
วาดเส้นเส้นเส้นเส้น
เส้นเส้นโค้งสมัยกุมภาว่าเส้นโค้งมันโค้ง
นะคะไม่ตรง
กินมั้ยฮะเส้นโค้งค่ะนักเรียนรู้หรือยัง
ครูฟ้าแต่วาดอะไรนักเรียนบอกว่าโอ๊ยผู้
ฟ้าว่าจะขอให้ของข้างบน
ทำไมผู้หญิงไม่สามารถที่จะหาผู้กันได้อ่ะ
กูป่ะ
กูกันอะไรคะอ๋ออาจจะเป็นนางแบบขีดอย่าง
เงี้ยเห็นรูฟ้าวาดเส้นโค้งข้างบนในขั้น
แม่นเหรอคะ 1 เส้นแล้วก็ต่อไปครูฟ้าวาด
อะไร
ว่าเส้นโค้งข้างล่าง
1 เส้นเส้นโค้งข้างบน 1 เส้น
ข้างล่าง 1 เส้นมารวมกันอันนี้เป็นรูป
อะไรคะครูฟ้าวงกลมวงรีอันนี้เป็นรูปวงรี
ค่ะนักเรียนวงรีไงช้าวาดวงรีนก็ไม่เห็นภู
เขาลงมาข้างล่างได้ค่ะวงรีโอครูฟ้าวาดวง
รีไนท์
4เหลี่ยมผืนผ้า
ชายค่ะ
ครูฟ้าวาดอะไรอ่ะแล้วต่อไปว่าอะไรคะครู
ฟ้าคือฟ้าก็จะวาดวงกลม
[เพลง]
วงกลม
Woo วงกลมยึดให้อีกใหญ่
ไอ้ห่าวงกลม
อย่าท้อแต่ครูฟ้าวาดแต่ถ้าครูหญิงใช่ไหม
ครูหญิงวาดวงกลมก็คือผู้หญิงว่าเป็นวงกลม
แบบนี้เลยอันนี้กรงไหมคะลมนอกลงนิดหน่อย
นะฮะแต่รุ้งฟ้าเวลาวาดรูปครูฟ้าค่อยๆวาด
เส้นเส้นเส้นเส้นเส้นเส้นเส้นเส้นๆแล้วก็
เป็นวงกลมใส่เส้นสั้นๆเนี่ยอ่าเส้นสอง
เส้นสามเส้น 4 เส้นผ้าเส้น 6 เส้นแล้วก็
เป็นวงกลม
ลบกันว่ากูฟ้า
วาดวงกลมไม่โอเคก็เลยว่าเส้นๆ
เป็นเทคนิคการวาดรูปใหม่
วาดวงกลมในฟรีแต่ว่าอะไร
สูงกว่า
ปู่อี่นมาแล้วอย่างดีกว่าสี่เหลี่ยมผืน
ผ้าให้ค่ะคู่หญิงนักเรียนรู้หรือยังคะว่า
กูฟ้าวาดอะไร
เรียนบอกคิดว่ารู้แล้วนะอะไรเอ่ย
ครูฟ้าว่าตาใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะครูหญิงตาๆป่าว
เวลาว่าตาต้องเริ่มจอดสี่เหลี่ยมผืนผ้างง
รีวงกลมใจต่อไปว่าอะไรต่อคะครูฟ้าต่อไป
เนี่ยมีตาแล้วใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าก็วาดวงกลม
เพราะว่าวงกลมใหญ่มะว่าตา
ใช่ไหมอันนี้คือลูกกะตานะคะนักเรียนอัน
นี้อ๋อวงกลมที่ครูฟ้าวาดก็คือลูกตาตาดำๆ
ตาดำ
We  Are  Look อตาชัยผู้หญิง Star ลูก
กระตาดำ
ลูกกะตาดำเนี่ยใหญ่ใช่ไหมแล้วก็เป็นวงกลม
แต่ว่าเราจะไม่เห็นวงนิ
นี้ในเราไม้เห็นเท่านั้นฟ้าก็จะ love นะ
คะขอเวลาที่ดูตาครูฟ้าดูตาครูหญิงตรงนี้
ใช่ไหมคะที่ใหญ่ๆที่เลย
วงรีขึ้นมาเนี่ยเวลาผู้หญิงดูตาหูฟ้าอ๋อ
จะลบ
วงกลมใช่ไหมกอล์ฟเปลี่ยนไก่ไม่ใช่วงกลม
แล้วในหากว่ามันใหญ่ไว้นิดนึงนะวันนี้ไม่
ใช่วงกลมเป็นอะไรวงอะไรคะผู้หญิงเป็น
ครึ่งวงกลมไหมครูฟ้าใช่ค่ะนักเรียนครึ่ง
วงกลมวงกลมก็เปลี่ยนไปเป็นนี้ค่ะเราเรียก
ว่าครึ่งวงกลม
ให้ครึ่งวงกลมนะคะครึ่งกลุ่มนั่งว่าอะไร
ต่ออีกไหมอ่ะต้องวาดวงกลม
สามเหลี่ยม
ต่อไปแล้วเนี่ย
จริงๆมันเปลี่ยนเลเยอร์ได้นะคะนักเรียน
เลยเอ้ออยู่ตรงนี้นะเวลาวาดรูปใช่ไหมว่า
จะเปลี่ยนเลเยอร์แล้วก็
ปรับอันนี้ให้เป็น
ๆจังๆออกป่ะ City นะคะ
ก็ต่อว่าอีก 1 ครั้ง
ให้มันเห็นเฉพาะว่าทัพใช่ไหมทับชายหากผู้
หญิงว่าทับนะว่าเรามันมีดีเทลใช่ไหมคะตา
เราเนี่ยก็จะเป็นเส้นข้างรถข้างบนนะคะ
ครึ่งวงกลมค่ะก็
เส้นข้างหลังค่ะ
ใช่ไหมค่ะก็จะปิดไปเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยตาของ
เราเนี่ยคือวงกลมฟ้านะ
ฮะแล้วเนี่ยตาของเราเนี่ยก็จะมีมีอะไร
นักเรียนมีไหมคะ
ยังไม่รู้เลย
มีอะไรอุ้ยกูฟ้าวาดเส้นอีก 1 เส้นไม่สี
ฟ้าว่าเส้นอีกหนึ่งเส้นอันนี้เราเรียกว่า
ฉันปลา
ฉันป่าเหมือนชั้น 1 ชั้นที่สองอย่างนี้
เหรอชั้น 1 ชั้น 2 ใช่รถ 2 ชั้นนะคะ r  3
ชั้นตาสองชั้น
นักเรียนมีไหมคะปลา 1 ชั้นตาสองชั้นชนะ
หญิงเนี่ยหญิงมีไหมผู้หญิงไม่มีผู้หญิงมี
ตา 1 ชั้นเท่านั้นนะคะนักเรียนเห็นตากรุ
หญิงชั้นเดียวหรือฟ้าเหรอสุภาก็
หน้าเหมือนผู้หญิงเหมือนขี้ผึ้ง
ต่อยเพราะแต่นักเรียนอาจจะเห็นตาสองชั้น
แบบนี้เนอะที่ครูฟ้าวาดครูฟ้าแล้วตรงนี้
อะไรตรงไหนคะผู้หญิงตรงนี้ไหมลูกค้าเห็น
รูปเมาส์ผู้หญิงวงกลมไว้ว่าผู้หญิงไม่
สามารถที่จะเอามาไม่เห็นเมาส์
ศิรินทิพย์วงกลมใช่ค่ะอันนี้มันเป็นมัน
เรียกเราเรียกว่าอะไรคะครูฟ้าเราเรียกว่า
หัวตาอ๋อเวลาหัวตาเนี่ยดูฟ้าก็ไม่ได้วาด
เป็นแหลมใช่ไหมเพราะตอนแรกครูฟ้าวาดตรง
นี้เนาะหัวตานะแหลมแบบนี้นะยำแหนมอ่าแต่
ที่นี่ตอนนี้คู่ฟ้าวาดใหม่เนี่ยไม่แหลม
ให้หามันจะเป็นอย่างนี้อ๋อมนๆเราเรียกว่า
บน
เลยนะเนี่ยแหลม
อันนี้แหลมหน้าแหลมเนี่ยมน
แหลม
มน
ภาว่านมันแบบมนหัวตาชัยค่ะคู่หญิงก็จะมี
หัวตา
แล้วก็อย่าลืมนะฮะมีหัวตาแล้วก็จะมีมี
อะไรอีก
อะไรคะตรงที่ครูฟ้าวงกลมอันนี้ก็คือ
หางตาค่ะอ๋อ
หัวตาหางตาใช่มั้ยหัวตาก็อยู่ใกล้กับสระ
หมู่
ตาสุริหารตาแต่หางตาเนี่ยแหลมใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะหางตาเนี่ยแหลมใช่มั้ยอ้างปลาหางราย
การอาหารตา
หัวตา
หางตาค่ะ
เสร็จหรือยังคะตากรุฟ้าแล้วก็จะมีมีอะไร
อีก
ครูฟ้าว่าเส้นข้างล่าง
ใต้ตาไม่ได้อยู่ข้างบนน้องเส้นอยู่ข้างบน
ตาเนี่ยนิตาสองชั้นแล้วเส้นอยู่ข้างล่าง
ข้างล่าง
เรียกว่าอะไรคะครูฟ้าเรียกว่าถุงใต้ตา
ให้ตาค่ะค่ะครูฟ้ามีถุงใต้ตาไหม
มีนะนี่ค่ะครูหญิงมีไหมคะถุงใต้ตา
ไม่มีโห
และ
แฟชั่นนาสไปท่านหรอ
ไม่เห็นอ้ะมีแต่
มองไม่เห็นขนาดนั้นใช่มีนะทุกคนมีเนาะนี่
เนาะถุงใจจัง
นักเรียนเห็นไหมนะคะสีฟ้าไม่ต้องทำกูหญิง
ก็เห็นนะใน
พรหน่อย
มันรู้สึกโอเค
เราก็จะมาลงสีกันใช่ไหมคะทุกคนถ้า
มันก็จะมี layer ขึ้นมานะคะอยู่ข้างล่าง
ใช่มั้ยเลเยอร์อันนี้เอาไว้ข้างล่างไม่
เห็นกูป่าวเอ่อเลยยยเอ้อ
เรื่องไม่ได้ค่ะไม่เป็นไรสีนะคะครูหญิงกู
ว่าจะใช้สีสีอะไรคะ
สีเบจก่อนนะคะอ่ะ
141 เนื้อปีเนื้ออะไรอ่ะถูกต้องหากผู้
หญิงประมาณกำลังขาสีเนื้อนะว่าจะเอาระดับ
ไหนจะไม่สีประดับของสี
เอาสีนี้ก็เปลี่ยนบัตรก่อนนะคะเปลี่ยน
พู่กันเปลี่ยนผู้กันลองหรอกเนี่ยฝีเนื้อ
ชั้นสีเนื้อคือสีของเราสีผิวสีเบจของนัก
เรียน 4 เนื้อคนถูกต้องค่ะแต่เราก็จะดู
ตาใช่มั้ยว่ามีสีอะไรอ่ะ
ก็จะเป็นสีครูฟ้าครูฟ้า
ลงสีเนื้อหาทั้งหมดเลยก่อนเหรอคะกับสเตป
ที่ 1 ก็คือลงสีเนื้อทั้งหมดเลยใช่ค่ะครู
หญิงลมสีนึงทั้งหมดเลยให้เราเห็นค่ะงือ
แล้วก็จะลงหัวตาหางตา
อ๋อลงสีเนื้อเหมือนเดิมเหรอคะอันนี้จะ
เป็นสีเนื้อแต่จะเข้มขึ้นอ๋อเค็มขึ้นว่า 4
เดือนที่หนึ่งชายหักเข้มขึ้นอย่างนี้ก็จะ
ลงสีลงสีนี้มาหางตานะคะ
เลือกสีรู
ครูฟ้าก็เลือกสีเข้มขึ้นอีก
i3 ที่ภูฟ้าลงก็เข้มขึ้นอะนี้สีที่เป็น
ปีที่สองสีที่ 3 เข้มขึ้นลงหางตาเหรอคะ
ครูฟ้าใช่ค่ะครูหญิงลงที่หางตา
ชัยค่ะเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยข้างในตาเรา
ข้างในตาเราเนี่ยก็จะมี
ตาดำและอาขาวค่ะครูฟังก็ต้องลงสีตาดำตา
ขาว
ชัยค่ะสีตาก็อาจจะเป็นสีฟ้านิดหน่อยมั้ง
อันนี้แล้วแต่แล้วนักเรียนค่ะก็จะลงสีนัก
เรียนเป็นฝรั่งใช่มั้ยตานักเรียนไม่ใช่สี
ดำคนไทยก็เรียกว่ารูปตาได้นะลูกตานะคะครู
ฟ้าลงตาขาวนะคะลงตรงลงสีที่เป็นส่วนของตา
ค่ะหมอเขา
ตาขาวใช่ไหมแล้วข้างในตาขาวก็จะมีตาดำค่ะ
ครูฟ้าก็ต้องหาสีดำ
สีดำแต่สีดำก็จะมีอ่อนกลางเข้ม
ฟ้ากำลังลงสีดำที่ลูกตาตาลอ่ะลูกตาดำยิ่ง
ตาเราเนี่ยมันจะเป็นสีน้ำตาลนะนักเรียนสี
น้ำตาลและคือสุดนี้น้องไม่ใช่สีดำอันนี้
อันนี้สีดำราคาสีดำ
ใช่อ่ะนี่จะเป็นสีน้ำตาลสีน้ำตาลเข้มนะคะ
สีน้ำตาลเข้มเนาะที่ที่ลูกตาเราใช่ค่ะสี
น้ำตาลหน้าสีน้ำตาลเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยก็ใช้สี
น้ำตาลนี่แหละทำอะไรคะอ๋อ
วาดเส้นขอบตา
ชัยหักสอนวาดเส้นขอบตานะคะตอนนี้คุณฟ้า
วาดขอบตาบนขอบตาบน
แล้วก็สีฟ้าก็กำลังแบบ - ใช่ไหมคะให้มัน
แบบดูเหมือนตาคนจริงๆอาๆมันจะได้เหมือนตา
คนนะเป็นเส้นขอบตา
ค่ะก็กำลังใส่เส้นขอบตาเสร็จและตาข้างใน
ของเราเนี่ยใช่ไหมเป็นตาขาวแล้วก็จะเพิ่ม
สีอีกหนึ่งเต็ปนะคะ
เพิ่มสีเหมือนเดิมไหมคะสีที่ครูฟ้าอ่ะใส่
ครั้งแรกครั้งที่ 2 เหมือนเดิมไหมไม่
เหมือนอันนี้สีขาวเห็นไหมค่ะอันนี้ก็คือ
สีสีเข้มขึ้นโอเคนะพึ่งเก็บเข้มขึ้นใช่
ไหมอันนี้สีขาวฟ้าก็จะเลือกสีเข้มขึ้นแบบ
นี้
แล้วก็ลง
แต่ไม่ลงทั้งหมด
มายไม่ลงทั้งหมดค่ะลงช่วงหัวตาหัวตาแล้ว
ก็หางตา
ชัยหานักเรียน
[เพลง]
ไปแล้วนะคะ
R ข้างใน
ฟ้าเพิ่มสีเข้มขึ้นก่อนเพิ่มสีเข้มขึ้น
เป็นน้ำตาล
เข้มมากขึ้น
ผู้ป๊าลงทั้งหมดไหมคะทั้งหมดในตาดำไหมไม่
หาลงนิดหน่อยเอ้อใช่ไหมนิดหน่อยไม่ใช่ไหม
เขาเรียกว่าไล่ระดับนะคะที่นี่แล้วก็มาก
ขึ้นมาขึ้นลงแบบไล่ระดับ
แล้วก็ทุกคนเนี่ยก็จะมีเขาเรียกว่าอะไร
อ้ะเงาใช่ไหม
เหงาก็จะเป็นสีขาวๆอย่างนี้นะคะค่ะใช่ไหม
เหงา
เหมือนเป็นลูกตาเขาขาวๆที่เราเห็นใช้หาง
เยาว์นะคะแล้วก็คู่ฟ้าเนี่ยจะ
R2 ชั้น
แล้วก็จะเลือกตรงนี้ก่อนคือ Copy สีเนื้อ
นะว่าจะเลือกเข้มขึ้นนิดหน่อย
คือก็จะลงสีเดิมเราต้องใสไม่รู้หาที่ไหน
ก็ก็อปปี้อันเก่าพี่อันนี้แล้วก็
สีเข้มขึ้นนะ
นี่มันไม่ค่อยเห็นเดี๋ยวก็จะเข้มขึ้นอีก
นิดนึงค่ะนะเพื่อเป็น
ใช่ว่าฉันตาที่ 2 เหรอคะใช่ค่ะครูหญิง
ชั้นตาที่สอง
หรือว่าจะ
เปลี่ยนนิดหน่อยค่ะอ๋อเกลี่ยสีใช้ไม่ได้
วาดขีดเป็นเส้นนะค่อยๆเกลี่ยเกลี่ยเกลี่ย
ให้มันดูแบบ
สวยนะคะ
แล้วก็ก็มีตาแล้วก็ต้องมีขนตาใช่ไหมขน
ทรายอยู่ตรงไหนของตาครูฟ้าขนตาเนี่ยอยู่
ข้างบนนะคะแล้วก็อยู่ตรงนี้แล้วก็อยู่
ข้างล่างค่ะอ๋ออยู่ตรงเส้นโป้ขาเส้นตรง
นี้นี้ฝนตาเราจะใช้สีน้ำตาลนะคะสีเหมือน
ตา
ก็จะทำขนปลาค่ะสีฟ้าก็จะวาดขนตาเป็นเส้น
เส้นขนตาโอ้โหฟ้าว่าเส้นขนตาแล้วนักเรียน
ไหมอ่าขนตานะคะอ๋อ
นี่มันในนิดนึงนะเดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงก็ตาม
ให้นักเรียนดูขนตาใช่มั้ยน้ำตาคนเราขนตา
เนี่ยกูฟ้าวาดขนตาแล้วที่ที่หางตาแล้วก็
ตอนนี้ว่าที่หัวตา
ขนตาบนนะมีฟ้าวาดขนตาบ่น
ตานะฝนซา
แต่
ก็มีขนตาแล้วก็อาจจะต้องมีขนตาที่
ข้างล่างนะข้างล่างก่อาร้างใช่มั้ยมีขนตา
บนก็ต้องมีขนตาล่างก็ครูฟ้าวาดขนตาล่าง
ที่หางตา
ช่องบาทตรงกลางตา
ตรงนี้กลางตา
แล้วก็กำลังว่าจากกลางตาเขาไปที่หัวตา
หรือเปล่า
ได้หักผู้หญิง
ประมาณนี้ใช่มั้ยขนตา
คนหน้าล่างเนี่ยอยู่แค่กลางตาสมัยไม่หัว
ตาไม่ถึงหัวตามายค่ะอ๋อเสร็จหรือยังคะตา
ครูฟ้าอ่ะมีเวลาหรือยังคะครูหญิงเวลาแล้ว
ค่ะหมดเวลาแล้วก็ประมาณนี้นะคะยังไม่ 100%
นะยังไม่ 100% แต่ว่าหมดเวลาแล้วนะนัก
เรียนแจกนักเรียนหรอก็ได้ดูแล้วก็ได้ฟัง
ใช่ไหมคะก็รู้ว่าอ้อถ้าอยากจะวาดตาที่ 1
2  3  4  5 ว่าเนี่ยทำยังไงอ่ะว่าเสร็จ
ลงสีใช่ไหมคะสีลงสีทำยังไงหรอวันนี้ครู
ฟ้าก็มาทำให้ดูนะคะส่วนครูฟ้า Stop ใช้
สกรีนได้นะภูพระลืมค่ะ
นะฮะก็วันนี้เนี่ยหมดเวลาแล้วผู้หญิงกับ
ครูฟ้าก็ไปก่อนนะคะนักเรียนอยากให้ครูฟ้า
เนี่ยว่าอะไรให้ดูอีกไหมก็คอมเม้นท์บอก
เราได้นะให้ค่ะหั่นโอเคใช้วิธีไม่เหมือน
กันจะรีบมีคนก็ไปก่อนเนาะสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ